[Applause]
I'm Taylor Taylor Swift took the stage
at Amazon musics Prime concert in New
York on Wednesday and bands went wild
[Applause]
and while she didn't directly address
her current situation with Scooter Braun
she did have a few subtle messages to
share I started out in country music did
anyone know that and one thing that has
been really wonderfully consistent
throughout the entire time
but I've been making music is that I
write all of it including a speech about
how she writes all of her own music it's
my favorite thing to to write songs and
then they go out into the world and I'm
really lucky that you guys are nice
enough today singing the words back to
me it's legitimately the coolest feeling
in the world
of course Taylor's upset that scooter
purchased her old label Big Machine
Records and now owns all her previous
master recordings of songs she wrote so
anyone who's been singing the words to
this Thank You Twitter seems to think
Taylor also took a small swipe at
scooter and Scott Borchetta who owned a
big machine during this portion of shake
it off really annunciate in a few key
lyrics just think well you've been
getting down mad about the loggers and
the dirty dirty cheats of the world
Taylor also gave fans a little insight
and her upcoming album lover out August
23rd the album is basically it's really
sort of a love letter to love itself and
I think that love is such a such an
inspiring thing to write about
especially for us songwriters because
love is so many things love is
complexity love his struggle of his pain
love his joy love his hope love is
equality fans also think this line where
she mentions love letter and that speech
is a hint about a track name because we
also saw this in her you need to calm
down video I don't want even I can't
only time will tell
[Music]